[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh darren revell sports business
reporter
for uh the business of sports betting
senior executive producer of the action
network
and i want to have darren on for a
couple of reasons the
digital world of uh sports collecting
with cards also a lot of these cards you
know we're finding out mike troud rookie
card or lebron or tom brady they're
going for over a million dollars
uh nba top shot there there's a lot of
questions here
and that's why we bring in darren uh
with the answers here
let let me start with uh the nba's top
shot so exactly what it is
uh is it and how did it start to explode
into
many many millions of dollars for these
uh these
photos okay so dan when you if you have
a 1952 mickey mantle
do you own the photo i do i own the card
correct
yeah so that's the way to think about it
you own
you own the one of those cards and you
have the right to sell
one of those cards it's the same thing
with top shot
you have a highlight where there's 49
that have been given out
and you own one of 49 you have the right
to sell
that one you don't get dividends if it
plays on sportscenter or if someone runs
it on youtube
you don't get any credit you only own
the right for that one
and so just like cards where there are
limited edition cards
there are a limited edition of these
highlights you get them out of digital
packs
and you have the right to sell them some
of these have sold for hundreds of
thousands of dollars
now the question is is this a real
market or is this a market that
listen we're living in a world where
crypto is 24 7. you wake up you lose 12
000 against well we're living in a world
where people
pumped up game stop you know a company
that has uh
uh age old popcorn ingrained in their
carpet and made them a blue chip company
what is real i can't tell you what is
real
but who gets the video to allow you to
get the snapshot who owns the video
of the nba owns the video the nba
creates the content and then top shot a
company
dapper labs is the company that makes it
puts it in the pack
the nba owns the video just like whoever
took the photo owns the video
or owns the card so the nba owns the
video there is no question about that
but it is on the blockchain so it is
secure
you own that particular right to sell
and then you can sell to someone else
and by the way here's an interesting
point the nba because it's on the
blockchain and it's secure
the nba knows when you sell it to
somebody else and when you sell it to
somebody else
they get a two and a half percent cut so
any time it's sold
all the way down the line they get a cut
which makes digital collectibles as long
as it stays
uh healthy more important than a
physical collectible because once you
sell a card
the league isn't getting a cut of it
anymore
i'm trying to think what's the most
famous
piece of video that would be in a in a
card
in nba history like what what is
available you know lebron's block on
andre iguodala in the nba finals is
pretty famous or
kyrie irving but that's the thing that's
the thing right like a card you don't
know what game it's from
people have never like michael jordan
uh his his 86 flare rookie that is
lighting up the world that was from a
random nets game
in 1985. so like you know
this allows you to connect to a
highlight and by the way they haven't
really opened up the past like
what would a 1988 jordan dunk contest
from the foul line
highlight sell for and are they even
going to be able to sell them
i i you would need michael jordan
why do i need jordan if the nba owns it
because the nba owned it at the time but
but jordan
jordan would have to approve of it now
because he's not part of the players
association oh okay
explain to me the recent physical card
phenomenon
where like who's driving this that
you know we know mickey mantle seems to
come up every other year or something
kobe bryant michael jordan
mike trout tom brady rookie card
uh who's behind all of this
i think it's what's behind all this dan
i think it's that
in covid we're looking for nostalgia
we're looking to reach back at times
when
things were normal uh people are going
through and cleaning their closets their
parents are cleaning their closets
they're finding things
and finally finally this is the key
we need some excitement in our lives we
need some dopamine to be rushing through
our brains and body
go try out an ebay auction see when you
win an ebay auction
it's an immediate rush it's almost like
it i'm telling you
it's not only about the card it's about
the feeling it generates when you win an
auction and so it becomes addictive in a
way why
sports gambling up we need to juice
ourselves up
because we're sitting at home with for
me for god's sakes i got a
got a twin boys in first grade right
outside my door
you know it's like what yeah but you're
not gonna spend a million dollars on a
tom brady rookie card just because
you're not gonna spend a million dollars
but
i've spent more money than i've ever
spent in my life in the last eight
months
what have you bought uh i
bought a uh what's the most expensive
thing i bought
um i mean i i i bought some serious
stuff i bought a
uh i bought a mike tyson 1986 panini
sticker
those things are going for sixty
thousand seventy thousand in some
conditions
i bought a jordan rookie i had to have
it 86 flair
you know so people are people are buying
and a lot of it is the feeling it
generates
and the camaraderie right like when you
buy it there's a collecting community
that you then share it forces you to
have
relations with people not in the bill
clinton
not in the bill clinton relations but
you know relations
okay but if you're looking at getting
into this
um can you dip your toe into this
or do you have to go into the deep end
no it's but it's it's very risky right
because you have to know who's
controlling certain markets so like
i'll give you an example one of my
friends who has plenty of money says
i want to do luka doncic and i say well
you got to be careful because
luca 21 to 25 year olds who don't have
the same net worth as you
they're going into luca cards and what
happens is if the market starts to crash
they're going to sell luca and then that
market will crash before everything else
so i tell people
try to figure out who's in what you want
to collect and
it starts with having you have to like
what you're doing right like
not all markets are going to stay up
forever i know that's a crypto thing and
oh it's just going to go to the moon
everything's going to go to the moon
it's going to all go up everything never
nothing ever goes down
don't start with that philosophy you
shouldn't get in trouble
but we've had you know mike trout had a
rookie card that why
why is it one of one i never understood
that they only make one
false scarcity right so like they
decided to create this mike
trout super fracture where it was the
lotto ticket it was the willy wonka
and so did i ever think that was going
to sell for 3.9 million
no but this whole we've created this
whole false scarcity if you remember dan
in the 80s and 90s the reason it crashed
is because they told us that the
kangaroo junior rookie card
was limited edition then we found out it
was the most produced card of all time
and these guys were running off sheets
of ken griffey jr to pay for their pizza
using it as currency so like we needed
to create a false scarcity
and so that's what we that's what the
card industry did this is one of 49 this
is one of one
and if you pull that willy wonka you
then get it graded
and then there's a whole grading
industry so like you get a michael
jordan in a one that was run over that
you
that you actually put literally in the
spokes of your bicycle
and th that in the worst condition is
going to sell for 4 000 now but if you
have a 10
that's 615 000. so the one thing that i
hate dan is when someone goes oh i have
this card
and i'm like it doesn't matter if you
have the physical card
if it's not a tent i know oh so that it
it
that that's how it's working i i had i
had somebody
who uh works for somebody who's pretty
famous in this business
and uh he was asking me you know
if i collected cards and i said you know
i got them but i don't know if they're
worth anything and
i said you know my son's got pokemon
cards he went wait
which ones what which ones the charizard
yes
and i said the charizard and he goes you
got to take pictures
like how many do you have when i go i
don't know my son have has him in a uh
a notebook or uh uh a scrapbook he goes
a binder
yeah yeah can you go you imagine you're
you're like i have a 1961 will
chamberlain fleer rookie
and he's like oh okay he's like but my
son is pokemon oh my god
like it's almost like disrespect you
know like you care more about a fake
dragon
than you care about chamberlain rookie
like this is messed up
this is messed up i had to take my phone
out
and open up the uh scrapbook
for you we were doing a lot you were
doing a a live viewing
yes and then you could hear the
disappointment in the guy
oh that's not a first edition from japan
forget about it dan i'm sorry no he goes
oh look at the edge
oh the oh the edges oh they're not done
those aren't okay
yeah those aren't worn with anything and
i went okay
so that that was my foray into possibly
being in that world for the first
question the hardest thing that i uh
that i do every day is
uh people texting me saying i got it and
i'm like that's not the one
it's in horrible condition you know and
it's all you know it's just
it in the end it's just disappointing
for a lot of people this is crazy
the most expensive card ever bought is
that the pie trainer one
is or no honestly mickey mantle's now
the five so uh mickey mantle nine from
1952 tops
sold for 5.2 million there are three
tens
and all those people are not selling
it's believed that that would be a 20
million dollar card
the great part about that is in 1952
mickey mantle was number
311 in the set it was the high number
series so it was the second
set that they came out with and in 1952
people were disinterested
after the first set so from 1952 to 1959
tops tried to sell those things for two
cents a card
couldn't do it so they they uh took
uh a lot of the cards and uh went in
staten island and dumped it on a barge
into the ocean and that created a false
scarcity or a real scarcity
and then the rest put it in bicycles and
the rest the moms threw it out
so my favorite line by the way is i wish
my mom didn't throw it out
and then i remind them that if their mom
didn't throw it out it would be worth
nothing anyway
so darren great to talk to you
and uh good luck with the twins all
right take care that's darren revell
the executive producer for the action
network